all right man what is this what are you
doing to us
stop it what's your name miss justine
well justine i love you
i love you i love all of you all right
and i don't care
what you've done god hates
the sin but he loves the sinner
example sandra who is sandra where is i
all right now sandra it it says here
that you want to kill a co-worker named
carol
yeah oh oh sandra i understand
when i'm frustrated i want to wring
someone's neck
exactly bring it hard so what do you do
what do you do when that feeling comes
over you
well i put on the hoodie that covers my
face
and i take the 47 bus line to a library
in a far away town
then i open a private browser on one of
their computers
and google home thinking of killing her
to see what mistakes people usually make
jesus today is a high alert day i can't
stress enough the importance of being
vigilant and cautious
in light of the serious threats we'll be
facing
dina's right so everybody keep an eye
out for anything
out of the ordinary okay good let's
watch out for people buying toilet paper
eggs shaving cream ketchup your
squeezables your squirtables everything
is a weapon today okay
what about guns those are fine
incidentally that costume is ridiculous
professor x doesn't drink martinis yes
but james bond does
oh come on dina stop being the halloween
version of scrooge whatever that is
oh booge boo scrooge i just thought of
that yeah don't be such a booge put on a
costume
peer pressure from a group of people i
don't respect now that's scary
i mean i can't believe i'm saying this
but sandra's the only other grown up
here
actually i am dressed up i'm you
um what shut up sandra shut up sandra
oh my god that's so cool you're gonna be
twinsies no we're not wait
you guys should stand together all day
i'm up for it yeah i'm gonna find a
costume to put on
excuse me can i excuse me
sir sir this lady here she when you have
a second sir
thanks for trying you're welcome
if you want to sit here while you wait
you can
okay i'll sit
when he confronted the witches it really
grounded him
exactly does your
husband or boyfriend like vampire
diaries as much as you do
oh i'm not seeing anyone what about jeff
who's jeff her serious boyfriend
oh right i do have a boyfriend
sorry excuse me
hi carol amy
is not my soul mate okay yes fine
when i first started working here years
ago
i i had a little crush on amy there i
said it okay
are you happy exactly and at one point i
had a crush on jonah and that's all in
the past yeah exactly
wait what you when did you did
you yeah no never mind it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter because if
even if we because with the timing and
everything it's yeah so you get it
so stop
he didn't know do you still love each
other what no
we never that we've moved on
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh and
you know and anyway it it doesn't matter
we we've all you know and and besides
you know i've
i'm with i've got i'm with um kelly
kelly yeah no i i know your name
obviously guys
this is amazing yeah i'm generally a
cynic but this
wow she didn't know that he didn't know
and now he knows that she knows we
get it sandra
[Music]
barbarians gate three is being released
today so i need everybody on their
a-game as this store is going to be
packed with video game nerds
and we don't want to risk a trampling
well we're never gonna totally prevent
tramplings oh no obviously we're never
gonna have
zero tramplings but we can have fewer
tramplings um can i set one of the video
games aside before we sell out
amy employees can't reserve merchandise
you know this
you're into video games after a long day
of work it's nice to have a glass of
wine and reach into a stable boy's chest
and pull out his still-beating heart
feed the birds
i just don't get how murdering people is
considered
fun i mean what happened to all those
innocent games you know like
frogger and q bert and donkey kong
innocent
kubert's about a big-nosed creepy little
freak that commits suicide when things
get hard frogger's
basically a frog holocaust i remember a
glitch in the original donkey kong
where it looks like the ape has a penis
sometimes when i'm playing the sims i
give myself a family
jesus christ so uh welcome back carol
uh we're all so thrilled to see how well
you're doing thanks
i'm so ready for a fresh start me too me
too
but just asking corporate knows what she
did
at my wedding yep they uh offered her a
store transfer
but uh lucky for us she declined like
i'm gonna leave this store
you guys are like family to me yeah so
so sweet
um well carol before we can get you out
on the floor again i've just been asked
to get a quick apology
okay great
oh you think i should apologize well
i mean you almost made me kill your cat
i did that you stole jerry for me you
rubbed your wedding in my face for
months and then you asked me to be your
maid of honor i mean
that was just cruel you told me i had to
i don't know amy it seems like she's not
ready to take responsibility
you know carol uh some people might
think actually
that um you are the one who should
apologize
oh oh i see um
the thing is when i spoke with cj de
bono at hr he said that my manager
should be impartial
and cj debota would know i mean he's
he's cj de bono he said i should call if
there were any hiccups or
yeah no no i don't i don't think we need
to call cj de bono
we can handle this internally um i just
need a a quick apology
sorry i heard an apology great let's get
back to work
compassion to save us from destruction
dear jewish god in your infinite power
mermaid
please
[Music]
you